[Musique]
tous les jours il ya énormément de lens
d'injustice et c'est vrai qu'il ya une
partie de moi y saisit pas pourquoi
c'est tombé sur moi
[Musique]
le 24 juillet 2018
donc c'était un mardi moi je travaillais
comme tous les autres jours j'ai marché
j'ai croisé donc un homme qui est passée
juste derrière moi en fait on s'est
croisés comme ça et je n'ai entendu
faire commencer à faire des espèces de
bruit dégueulasse et pas tout simplement
moi ça m'a énervé donc ce que j'ai fait
c'est que j'ai lâché un ta gueule puis
bah il a entendu puisque là il était en
train de mater et il s'est énervé
directement savait pas au début j'ai su
après cette scène elle a été filmée par
une caméra de surveillance du café
[Musique]
j'avais une terrasse entre nous
et il a attrapé un cendrier de la
terrasse il l'a jetée vers moi
l'incendié a traversé la terrasse les
passer à côté de ma tête ou moins
imaginaires insulté et du coup lui ça
l'est encore plus énervé il est revenu
en arrière et donc m'a frappé
[Musique]
après l'agression je suis rentré chez
moi dans un état de choc je tenterai
pleurais j'avais la tête tout rouge je
me suis levé j'ai fait bon je vais je
vais je vais me battre
enfin vraiment je suis allé je fallait
me mettre de l'eau froide et je suis
ressorti avec le visage tout gonflé je
retournais vos parts hier soir alors que
je rentrais chez moi vers le boulevard
de la villette dans le 19e
arrondissement à paris
j'ai croisé un homme le harcèlement
c'est au quotidien ces hommes se croient
tout permis dans la rue se permettent de
nous humilier et qui ne supporte pas
qu'on s'en occupe c'est inadmissible il
est temps que ce genre de comprendre que
ce genre de comportements cessent
[Musique]
et le lendemain matin c'était déjà la
folie en fait
enfin joaillier jeter dans mon ordi je
voyais les commentaires qui tombe est
tombé tomber bonjour marie bravo pour ta
force et ton courage ne lâche rien
espérant que celui là sera retrouvés et
condamnés
inadmissible vous avez eu raison de
porter plainte il s'est passé un truc de
fou quand je me suis réveillée dimanche
matin c'est que mon téléphone il avait
des dizaines des centaines de
notification j'ai absolument pas compris
ce qui m'arrivait j'avais des messages
sur facebook sur twitter sur instagram
les journalistes qui me contactent et
plein plein plein de demain deux jambes
estime beaucoup de médias aussi de
l'étranger puisque et cnn et bbc la
turquie le brésil l'australie
l'argentine
on en vient à ces images qui ont choqué
l'opinion publique
elle s'appelle marie sa vidéo a été vue
des milliers de fois sur les réseaux
sociaux
il est intéressant avec cette vidéo
c'est qu'elle a été mise en ligne en
juillet 2010 et fin juillet et ça c'est
hyper important et ça explique pourquoi
ça a fait un tel buzz parce qu'en
réalité on est dans un moment où
l'actualité est un peu morte
on a un peu fait retomber toute
l'excitation autour de la coupe du monde
champion du monde etc
on est en train de passer à une autre
phase et en même temps on sort d'un
moment mis tout avec la libération de la
parole etc
il est un scandale qui secoue le monde
du cinéma et en particulier hollywood
les accusations de harcèlement sexuel
d'intimidation et parfois de viol
accable le producteur américain harvey
weinstein avant la phéromone stein ya eu
la sphère dsk ya eu la sphère bill cosby
jimmy sa ville en grande bretagne c'est
des gros à faire dans différents pays
là la ferme einstein c'est comme si
c'était un trop plein et à la
mobilisation sur les réseaux sociaux qui
s'enchaînent et ça s'enchaîne très vite
[Musique]
le hashtag mitu et puis en france on a
balance le port et puis surtout c'est
suivie de manifestations dans la rue on
souvient à paris de ces femmes ont
manifesté avec les pancartes en disant
moi aussi et en répondant à leurs
histoires sur des pancartes c'est écrit
c'est visible on les voit elles sont
dans la rue sur la place publique
et ça ça a eu un impact phénoménal non
peut-être ne se rassure entre nous de
savoir qu effectivement j'étais pas
sonar brandi on est beaucoup des très
nombreuses et nombreux et on a envie de
faire le chemin sont actuellement en
france qu'on observe c'est que les
violences sexistes et sexuelles ne sont
pas assez sanctionné le gouvernement ne
l'acceptent pas et c'est pour cette
raison que nous avons travaillé en
profondeur de longue date pour proposer
un projet de loi qui vise à mieux
condamner les violences sexistes et
sexuelles
donc ne nous voulons verbaliser le
harcèlement de vue le harcèlement de oui
ils entravent la liberté d'aller et
venir des femmes et ça fait des
générations que les femmes et les jeunes
filles le subissent sans qu'aucune
politiques publiques ne soient mises en
oeuvre pour lutter contre cela nous
voulons l'interdire et le verbaliser via
des amendes d'un montant de 90 à 3000
euros selon les cas
[Musique]
et sur ce contexte arrive la vidéo de
marie la guerre une vidéo qui est hyper
forte parce qu'on voit très bien ce qui
s'y passe
et là tout d'un coup tout le monde s'en
empare le lundi il ya la république en
marche qui m'a indiqué au sénat pour une
séance qui avait lieu le mardi
bisoli de la loi schiappa donc j'ai
rencontré j'ai rencontré mon avocat
juste avant et en fait on a épluché la
loi et qui je ne savais pas si j'allais
accepté parce que en fait on se retrouve
d'un coup dans ce tourbillon ai donné ma
réponse à la remise en marche leur ai
dit que j'ai accepté de venir mais que
vous les paquets de récupération
politique
donc j'y suis allé et en fait
pratiquement tous les sénateurs et
sénatrices qui prenait la parole dans
leurs discours le mentionner tout est
hyper perturbant voilà j'étais dans le
dans les gradins j'écoutais puis
j'entendais mon nom ici dès mon
agression y cité mon nom et voilà
c'était assez perturbant
[Musique]
la semaine dernière une jeune femme a eu
à subir ces agissements relevant du
harcèlement de rue qui se sont prolongés
jusqu'à des injures puis une agression
physique
la question de la lutte contre le
harcèlement de rue n'est donc ni plus ni
moins qu'un enjeu de civilisation qu'un
enjeu de respect des valeurs
fondamentales de la république française
[Musique]
ce qu'il faut comprendre à propos de
marie la guerre c'est que évidemment
c'est une militante c'est à dire que les
réseaux sociaux l'emballement médiatique
pourrait nous faire croire que elle
arrive là elle se promène dans la rue
elle dit iginla un agresseur elle se
fait frapper la vidéo circule et là tout
d'un coup tu as là elle est porte parole
d'une cause mais pas du tout en fait
mary la guerre ça fait des années
qu'elle est qu elle est militante
j'étais totalement consciente que ce qui
est en train de se passer c'était hyper
ponctuelles on va dire que là c'est
intéresser tout le monde parce que ça a
choqué mais tous m'ont été outré par les
violences faites aux femmes mais deux
jours après bon bah on passe à autre
chose quoi est on pour moi c'était hyper
important en fait de maintenant de tout
donner au détriment de ma santé
malheureusement au détriment de mon
travail de vraiment de tout donner à ce
moment là pour faire porter le message
le plus possible je me suis entouré de
femmes de féministes que je connaissais
de près ou de loin qui m'ont conseillé
sur voilà comment ajouter ma pierre à
l'édifice et donc on a décidé de créer
un site internet qui s'appelle donc nous
tout harcèlement point fr qui est
vraiment dans le but de recueillir des
témoignages en une semaine on a reçu
1000 témoignages donc c'est énorme
encore aujourd'hui je les ai pas tous eu
parce que c'est pas possible parce que
déjà ça prend beaucoup d'énergie
il ya des choses vraiment difficile j'ai
eu des trucs de viol c ur c'est que ça
arrive mais bon ça fait toujours des
frissons pendant le lit et de lens est
aussi je pense que marie la guerre avec
peut-être un petit peu sous-estimé la
difficulté et le poids que ça faisait
peser sur ses épaules toutes les
militantes que j'ai intérêt
m'ont dit qu'à un moment elle n'en
pouvait plus il ya des moments où elles
doivent s'arrêter
elles doivent reprendre leur souffle et
et ça c'est pas forcément possible quand
on a une vague médiatique sur laquelle
on se sent obligé de se re c'est pour au
nom des autres femmes au niveau de la
santé s'était pas c'est pas génial et je
il ya le côté de l'agression mais il ya
aussi la médiatisation
j'ai commencé à avoir des crises
d'anxiété des crises d angoisse
ça me coupe les haut parleurs l'appétit
j'étais incapable de manger le sommeil
s'était pas beaucoup mieux aux quelques
jours je faisais des cauchemars que
j'étais dans mon lit nier que j'avais la
porte de chez maxim gré que j'avais
plein de journalistes qui me suis jeté
sur moi
le commissariat m'appelle et me dit ben
voilà on a retrouvé de la retrouver
votre un suspect qui aurait qui pourrait
tout à fait votre agresseur il en garde
à vue il faut que vous veniez
l'identifier dès le lendemain un meuble
soir même une téléphone 1 c'est reparti
ça sonnait et évidemment on a recommencé
à parler de moi
les commentaires gentil ont repris mais
aussi les commentaires qui relève de
cyber harcèlement
j'en ai qui m'ont envoyé des menaces de
mort des trucs du genre
il aurait dû tuer si je te crois je te
démolir la mâchoire qui pourra plus
manger sauf avec une paille tout comme
ça ouais enfin c'est très près de laon
à chaque fois que une femme une
militante quand la parole pour
s'exprimer sur les droits des femmes
pour dénoncer sans suis systématiquement
une phase de cyber-harcèlement plus ou
moins fortes
c'est ce qui arrive à marier la guerre
elle s'exprime sur les réseaux sociaux
est donc en face à leur retour de bâton
est hyper puissant un symbole un an
après la vague du mouvement me to qui
avait vu le jour dans la foulée de la
ferraille stein marie la guerre cette
jeune femme qui s'était fait gifler dans
la rue à paris par son harceleur a gagné
une bataille aujourd'hui en justice un
sourire timide et quelques larmes après
l'énoncé du jugement
l'agresseur de marie la guerre vient
d'être condamné à un an de prison dont
six mois avec sursis pour violences
aggravées
le comportement de l'agressé est
indéniablement liée à la condition de
femmes de maris la guerre a affirmé le
procureur marie elle est devenue le
symbole de toutes les femmes qui un jour
se sont faits
agressé harceler interpellé par un
agresseur dans le but de marie c'est de
se dire ok demain
les femmes elles vont arrêter de se
sentir coupable
elles vont au contraire se sentir forte
et puissante parce qu'elles le sont et
donc elle veut pas se faire elle vous
continuez à parler pour elle c'est sa
responsabilité
voilà seule chose que j'en tire c'est
plutôt la satisfaction d'avoir porté un
message qui est hyper important y'a rien
de plus satisfaisant que quand on se bat
pour quelque chose qu'il hyper important
qui juste qui concerne vraiment tout le
monde et qui est urgent est de pouvoir
être entendue et de recevoir de la de la
considération enfin des retours positifs
c'est quand même en termes de
satisfaction personnelle c'est c'est ce
qu'il ya de plus important pour moi
c'est prix moteurs
[Musique]
la marche nous tout qui a vu le 24
novembre
c'était vraiment quelque chose de très
fort moi je les soutenu depuis le début
je faisais partie des personnalités qui
soutiennent la marche
vu que mon nom était connu c'est avec
plaisir que je l'associé à la marche
pour lui donner de la dignité je veux
lui donner tous les jours il ya
énormément de violence d'injustice et
c'est vrai qu'il ya une partie de moi
qui saisit pas pourquoi c'est tombé sur
moi mais après je me dis c'est pas à mon
endroit moi la personne c'est juste
plutôt ce que ça représente pour les
autres donc dans ce sens là y'a pas se
sentir légitime je pense ça aurait pu
tomber sur n'importe qui
[Musique]